maman je suis un problème ils en ont
rien à faire de moi voilà les propos
d'un jeune garçon en situation de
handicap de ma circonscription
l'inclusion des enfants souffrant de
handicaps ne peut passer que par la
prise en compte des conditions de
travail de ceux qui les accompagnent
[Musique]
c'est vrai les mobilisations répéter
vous ont conduit à prendre quelques
mesures mais qui demeure largement
insuffisante les aes h demande va
exercer leurs missions dans des
conditions dignes et respectueuse des
enfants contre à temps partiel contrats
courts des salaires de misère des
affectations de dernière minute bref un
statut incertain qu'attendez-vous alors
monsieur le ministre pour donner accès
aux als h à des formations qualifiantes
à la hauteur de leur mission
[Musique]
ce que ces milliards là quand on voit
qu'il y en à 2,2 aujourd'hui pour les un
es h que nous pourrions habilement
doubler ce montant parce que les
accompagnants des élèves qui sont en
situation de handicap eux ils seraient
bien quoi en faire 2 6 milliards
[Musique]
nous avons créé une véritable carrière d
un message en 2017 lorsque nous sommes
arrivés en responsabilité cela
correspondait à 70 mille contrats aidés
même un peu moins ce que nous appelons
les ars h aujourd'hui au moment où je
vous parle c'est 125000 cdd même parfois
des cdi nous donnons 60 heures de
formation par an aux avait sage nous
avons amélioré la qualité de cette
formation bien entendu la situation
n'est pas parfaite et je suis très
sensible aux problèmes que vous avez
soulevés et qui sont bien réels
[Musique]